-I want to ask -- I don't want
to turn this around to you
But we found
a high-school photo of you
And do you believe
this haircut --
And, again, use your backgroun
as a prosecutor.
Obviously you know the law
You know the Constitution.
Is this an impeachable haircut
Is that --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- I wish I could say
that is Russian misinformation
-Yeah.
-But there are witnesses
who could come to my defense
for that.
But I'm not going to allow
any of them to come forward.
-Yeah, there you go.
It is --
You definitely look like
you're about to, like,
get in a karate fight and
we're not going to root for you.
-Yeah, yeah.
All the kids were --
-Yeah. Was it California?
-Yeah, the whole soccer team
Dublin High School. Go, Gaels.
We were all -- Yeah.
-That was a look you all had
There was another -- This
was one of the fun scandals.
Because every now and then
there's a fun one that comes up.
You were part of one.
And this is actually -- Thes
are actually about Fartgate.
You know about Fartgate.
These are real things.
We'd like to show the video.
Now, this is not something -
When this happened,
you did not hear it?
-I did not hear it.
-Yes.
-I just want to say,
I think we should draw
on the words of the 21st-century
philosopher Shaggy.
It wasn't me.
-Okay, there you go.
But let's look,
and we'll let the audience
take a look for themselves
-Chris, so far, the evidence
is uncontradicted
that the President
used taxpayer dollars
to ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat...
[ Fart ]
...an election,
and the complaint that I'v
heard from Republicans...
[ Laughter ]
-Now, this was immediately -
This was what everybody
was talking about.
But, again, you --
You're having a conversation
with Chris Matthews.
-Yes. Serious conversation
-Serious conversation, earpiec
in, so you don't hear that
-No.
-How do you find out
that it happened?
-I went to dinner that night
with some buddies in town
from Dublin High School --
we're all in Washington.
And Chrissy Teigen
tweets about it.
My wife, who follows everythin
she says, texts me and says,
"Did you just fart
on national TV?"
[ Laughter ]
-And you're claiming this --
absolutely not?
-Total exoneration.
We are going to slow it down
one more time.
[ Laughter ]
Because I feel like if we se
anything in your face,
this would be how we'd kno
if you're telling the truth.
Let's take one more look.
-Ask the Ukrainians
to help him cheat...
[ Fart ]
...an election.
And the complaint that
I've heard from Republicans...
[ Laughter ]
-See, now, that -- Exactly
You need Rudy to represent you
"He couldn't have done it!
He wasn't there!"
"Rudy, he was there."
Well, this -- You know,
obviously you were --
You're saying
this is basically --
Donald Trump and the story
that we're talking about,
this has been something
you've been dealing with
for basically three years.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Do you watch it and think
at the very least there will b
some sense of closure,
however this ends?
Is that something that
you're looking forward to?
-January 20, 2021, Donald Trum
is not going to be president
whether he's removed befor
or voted out, yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You ran briefly.
-Yeah.
-It was a very large field
-Cup of coffee.
-Cup of coffee, exactly. Yeah.
The Moonlight Graham
of this year's...
-[ Man laughs ]
-Thank you, Wally.
[ Laughter ]
-He liked that one.
-Do you feel like there's
a wealth of good choices still
for the American people
who are watching these debates
-I do,
and the crux of our campaign
was this idea that
we shouldn't have to live
with gun violence
being the norm.
And so I announced in Parkland
and was inspired
by those students
who marched and beat
19 NRA-endorsed members
of Congress in 2018.
And I'm proud that every
candidate today is, you know
making anti-gun violence
a top priority.
And so I think every candidate
is capable of
beating Donald Trump
and will put that importan
issue on the forefront.
-Hey, thank you so much
for making the time
and being here and
clearing stuff up for us.
Congressman Eric Swalwell,
everybody.